on this wednesday night from washington
d.c
joe biden edges to the finish line
no one's been declared president yet but
both candidates
are confident will emerge victorious as
far as i'm concerned
we already have one trumps threats of
lawsuits
and the race is too close to call i urge
everybody to remain patient
class fears of the outcome and the
fallout it's kind of scary
and the deepening political divide i
think our political system is broken
is unity in america possible
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
from washington d.c the election is over
but the world is still waiting to find
out who will be the next president of
the united states
joe biden is calling for all the votes
to be counted and donald trump is
threatening lawsuits and trying to stop
the counting it is biden who is edging
closer to victory
michigan and wisconsin have now both
flipped to the democrats
this is what biden said this afternoon
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners
here's why he's sounding so confident
after picking up michigan biden is now
six electoral college votes away from
the 270 needed to get to the white house
those are the ap
numbers we use and a win in nevada would
get him there
there are now just five states where the
results aren't clear yet they are the
ones in gray on this map alaska will
more than likely go republican the
others pennsylvania north carolina
georgia and nevada
could go either way
donald trump has not spoken to the media
today his team now has been busy
filing lawsuits and again without any
evidence accusing the democrats of
stealing the election
his lawyer rudy giuliani made
allegations today of widespread voter
fraud he claimed
trump has won the election and said it's
just a matter of counting
the votes fairly joe biden does have
more paths to victory than donald trump
our eric sorensen is on top of all the
maps and the math
eric where do the numbers stand and
where are they likely to go donna
if you were looking at this map a little
after midnight it did not look promising
for joe biden
he needed to win multiple states that
donald trump had won in 2016
and had only one to show for it arizona
but then the votes kept coming in he
started to get a little closer in
several states
and by this afternoon wisconsin had
flipped a democratic blue
and suddenly biden has the wind at his
back
it was a long night in milwaukee as
thousands of ballots were counted
and later with police escort dropped off
by the elections commissioner at the
courthouse
a race so close it could not be called
until virtually all of the votes had
been counted
the final wisconsin tally about a 20
thousand vote win for joe biden
less than a percentage point ahead of
president trump
close unofficially complete and above
board
every piece of data is publicly
available
and so there's no opportunity to add
additional votes to the tally right we
have no reason to believe that there are
any other
ballots that have not yet been counted
and included as part of those unofficial
totals
by late afternoon michigan was also put
into the biden column
they're still counting in nevada and
several more states a long process for
election workers and an agonizing
waiting game for americans
other key races too close to call in
nevada
biden leads by about a point with a lot
of votes still to count
trump has narrow leads in georgia and in
north carolina
in pennsylvania his lead has been
trimmed to a few points
with hundreds of thousands of early
votes still to be counted mostly cast by
democrats
so wisconsin and michigan have pushed
biden to a clear lead of 264 electoral
votes
trump at 214 as declared by associated
press
the states left have 60 electoral votes
trump has a lead in alaska that would
add to his total
analysts think north carolina could go
to trump and for the moment he leads in
georgia
biden though is closer to the finish
line and he leads in nevada
if he wins nevada and holds the rest
through any recounts
biden would be at 270 the number to win
the presidency
pennsylvania would give him an even
bigger lead but if instead it went over
to trump
it would be a very very close finish
there are other combinations
but biden appears to have more
agonizingly close paths to 270.
as the votes get counted state officials
bristle at any suggestion of dishonesty
give the public servants the opportunity
to do their job
and what i will tell you is that here in
pennsylvania we're going to follow the
law
president trump wants to challenge the
process but he's challenging a
fundamental precept of any election
you vote then you count the ballots all
of them
eric sorensen global news toronto
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
is with me jackson still millions of
votes to be counted we have to make that
point but
it looks like the momentum is on joe
biden's side now what are the options
for donald trump
uh you know they're few and far between
and they seem to be a path through the
courts at this point which is why you
saw the president's uh
children and rudy giuliani out there
launching this one court challenge in
pennsylvania
pennsylvania to try and stop the count
there they're doing something similar in
michigan as well but i have to tell you
they don't have a great track record
with these court challenges
even in front of trump-appointed
republican judges
and the reason for that is they're
making these allegations of voter fraud
or insufficient time to scrutinize the
ballots
they haven't actually offered up any
proof in any of these cases so donna
that remains a real roadblock for trying
to move these forward for the trump
campaign
and jackson the counting is going on is
there a timeline on when we might get
some clarity on these numbers
it's a slow process you know officials
in nevada told us that they might not
release any new results until tomorrow
now it seems like some might trickle out
tonight
georgia still has a lot of counting to
go almost 200 000
ballots this is slow arizona's working
on 600 thousand ballots so
we may get some more clarity tonight
donna we may not we may have to wait
until tomorrow but i can tell you
president trump has called what is known
as a lid at the white house which means
he's not expected to make any public
appearance through the rest of the
evening
all right jackson thanks so much well as
we said votes are still being counted
in some key states and now there's news
the us postal service lost
track of roughly 300 000 ballots they
entered the postal system apparently but
there's no confirmation they were
delivered to election authorities
u.s postal service officials were called
before a federal judge today for failing
to comply with a court-ordered sweep of
their facilities
to try to find those missing ballots
concerns were raised about the postal
service's ability to handle the
unprecedented number of ballots
after the new postmaster general a donor
to trump's campaign
made changes that slowed mail delivery
in the lead-up to the election
critics say the intention was to
suppress votes particularly
in swing states
michigan is also a battleground state
and late today it went
to joe biden many of the final ballots
came from democratic strongholds like
detroit and today
there was unrest at a building in that
city where ballots are being counted
poll watchers are allowed in michigan
where vote counting is happening
but the room was at capacity angry
crowds began
pushing our jeff semple is in detroit
tonight jeff
what more can you tell us well donna
take a look here just behind me
a few dozen protesters and a large
number of police who are now standing
guard
in front of this building where some of
the final ballots are being counted here
in michigan
a battleground state of course where
tensions around that vote count
are running very high a day of
demonstrations
in detroit tell me what democracy looks
like
protesters demanding that every vote is
counted
after president trump launched a lawsuit
to stop the count
in the battleground state if you want to
declare the game is over before halftime
it depends that you ultimately are not
interested
in all of us winning a group of
republican supporters tried to force
their way into this building where the
ballots were counted
but were stopped by police
with michigan's tally extremely tight
the detroit area in wayne county
was among the last to count its ballots
a lot of population there
a lot of democratic voters and at least
in the city of detroit we know out of
nine out of 10 of those voters
are voting for mr biden a city 80
percent black
with around 40 percent unemployment
during the peak of the pandemic
it's just it's a difficult time you know
this auto worker was laid off this
summer
and cast his ballot for biden i think
everyone in detroit wants
change back in 2016 donald trump won
michigan by the slimmest of margins 0.3
percent
in part because detroit didn't show up
looking at the polls i think everybody
thought that this was going to be a
blowout for hillary
and that didn't happen so this time
groups pushed
to get out the vote working the phones
and offering free rides to polling
stations
we don't believe the polls so it's like
no act like he's really behind
and vote like your life matters because
it really does they deployed this
smartphone
app that syncs a person's contacts with
the voter list
so rather than people just getting cold
calls or cold text messages
we have uncle henry reach out to cousin
jamie because that's who's going to
listen
this grassroots group made 25 000 calls
and sent 8 million text messages
the result detroit's voter turnout is
projected to be its highest
in decades and the impact of those votes
was hard to miss
when people here woke up this morning
donald trump was still
leading in the state of michigan but
suddenly joe biden pulled ahead
after a large number of votes were
reported from the city of detroit
and as we know biden never looked back
our projections now showing
that the democrats are expected to
reclaim the state
of michigan donna
all right jeff semple in detroit thank
you patience is needed in
pennsylvania coming up when a winner
could finally be declared in that swing
state
global national is back from washington
in just a moment
welcome back we're going to take you to
pennsylvania now where ballot counting
is not expected to be complete until
friday though as
things are shaping up joe biden might
not need to win pennsylvania to win the
white house
still nothing is being taken for granted
and the workers doing the counting are
being
meticulous mike armstrong explains
it's one of those things where even if
you're warned it might happen
you're surprised when it does we are
exactly where we said we would be
well despite repeated warnings for weeks
that counting would be slow
many in pennsylvania find themselves as
the saying goes
on pins and needles i didn't feel
particularly good waking up this morning
it's kind of it's kind of scary it's
like anticipating the outcome
the good news is that we voted that's
the best news of all
the unfortunate news is going to take a
while for us to find out
who won and that's fine
[Applause]
this is one of the places people are
watching including media from around the
world
inside one of the biggest and busiest
counting operations in the state
officials say they're pumping out
updates as fast as possible
but responsibly counting votes cast by
mail
if you're going to do it right and
you're going to do it accurately because
there's no other choice
takes a little bit of time a major hitch
is that this state hasn't done
no excuse early voting before it went
from 290
000 early ballots in the last election
to about 2.6
million this time now donald trump still
has a sizable lead in this state
that's expected to shrink as more
ballots are counted that's because of
where they come from mostly
democratic-leaning counties around
philadelphia and pittsburgh
and they're mostly mail-in ballots those
are expected to lean toward joe biden
because for weeks
democrats were telling supporters to
vote early well
counting everything could take until
friday and despite the pressure
officials say they won't be rushed we'll
be done as soon as we're done
as for legal battles the state's
secretary general says the ground rules
were set going into election day
if challenges come he basically says
bring it on he's confident but right now
he's focused very much on
counting first donna
as it should be mike armstrong in
philadelphia thanks
beyond the uncertainty about who will be
president there were historic firsts in
other races across the country
delaware elected sarah mcbride as the
first openly transgender
state senator in the u.s and six other
transgender and non-binary people were
elected or re-elected
in state races new york is sending the
first two openly
gay black men to the u.s house of
representatives
and black lives matter activist corey
bush is the first black woman to
represent
missouri in the u.s congress the 44 year
old nurse is a single mother
and was once homeless an insider's take
on the u.s election ahead my
conversation from earlier today with the
former u.s ambassador
to canada bruce heyman
for more perspective on the u.s election
bruce heyman joins me from aspen
colorado he was the us ambassador to
canada
from 2014 to 2017. mr hayman thanks
again for speaking with us
we still don't know the final result but
what is clear is that neither candidate
won a landslide in this election you're
a democrat what does that tell you about
the campaign joe biden ran
well you know it's a hard-fought
campaign for every last vote
and the campaign we were getting signals
over the few days going into the
election itself
that joe biden does not need
pennsylvania and florida to win
based on the mathematics and paths they
were looking at
and so that gave me a hint right off the
bat
that this was not going to be the
tsunami that i know a lot of democrats
were hoping for
but at the end of the day it's very
clear one thing you need to do
get 270 and the path to 270
and i think joe's right on track for
that
tens of millions of americans voted
again for donald trump
this election seems to have solidified
his support
republicans maintain control of the
senate whether joe biden wins or not was
he the right candidate to run against
donald trump
well if he wins he was definitely the
right candidate the problem is
that whether it was 2016 or 2020 i think
democrats need to sit back and get a
better understanding
of what it is about half the country
that can
find donald trump so appealing and that
we need to address that because you know
i think the next
president and hopefully it's joe needs
to bring the country together
and unite us as opposed to divide us and
we need to figure out ways to do that
and it's not going to be an easy task in
a pandemic economic challenges
racial divide and then all the
geopolitical issues we face
the job for the next president is going
to be a very difficult one
we know they're going to be some
recounts apparently some legal
challenges too what's your sense of when
we'll have a clear result
i am convinced based on my conversations
that we've had today with the legal team
on the biden team
i think they have they're on the right
side of this issue
but look it's it's expected the
president sues everybody in business
in his personal life litigation is his
middle name and so
so this is not unexpected from donald
trump in the final throes of keeping his
presidency
bruce heyman former u.s ambassador to
canada thanks
thank you be well
now to the pandemic for the first time
the us has recorded 100 000
new covid19 cases in a single day and in
canada the country's top doctor is
warning
severe cases of covid19 may rise in the
coming days and weeks
as the number of reported
hospitalizations and deaths does
lag behind the new cases as of today
there are 367 people with covid19 in
ontario hospitals that's the highest
number of hospitalizations in ontario
during
the second wave ontario also reported 16
new deaths
that's the highest single day death toll
since mid-june
winnipeg police say they will be
cracking down on people who ignore the
public
health restrictions especially those
hosting big parties
winnipeg recently moved into the red
zone the most restrictive category and
capped gatherings at members
of one household plus five other people
police say they're prepared to hand out
fines of nearly thirteen hundred dollars
for people who exceed that limit
officers will also step in to break up
large gatherings and record the names of
those in attendance so proper contact
tracing
can be done in quebec if a restaurant
owner
in the province's red zones opens their
dining room they could face
fines of up to six thousand dollars and
that goes for any customers
who choose to dine in those open
restaurants quebec reported 1029 new
cases today that is the most
in the country healing america next
after a bitter election can a divided
nation find a path
to unity we're back from washington
in a moment
welcome back to washington this election
has reinforced how politically divided
america remains
political opponents should not be
enemies and yet that is too often the
reality in this country
how can americans get beyond that our
heather urex west spent the day talking
to people about the future
2020 has been a year where division and
inequality
has come to a painful head it's okay to
be on either side at all and
and and disagree about politics that's
what this country is
built upon but when hate is injected
into
politics is what this country is not
supposed to be about
and yet the gap between sides has never
felt so wide
this minnesotan says he couldn't bring
himself to even cast a ballot this year
i think our political system is broken
at this point to be honest with you
the divisiveness that both sides bring
to the table because we advocate for
things like humane and open immigration
and
more progress and racial justice it was
pretty disappointing
greg king says he had hoped to see a
swell of support for immigrant
communities at the ballot box
instead he feels candidates who
campaigned on anti-immigration rhetoric
were rewarded instead in a city where
divisions turned to violence earlier
this year
the hangover to this election feels
heavy
but there is hope here as well i think
the main thing it takes is
being in community with each other
working side by side with each other
and you know building you know
businesses together
the better you get to know your
neighbors the easier it's going to be to
see that they're people
who deserve rights and that's basically
it
building unity bit by bit heather urex
west global news
minneapolis
that is global national for this
wednesday from washington d.c
i'm donna friesen the day after the 2020
american presidential election in the
united states feels like the political
future is still on hold
while every vote is counted thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you